[Music]
john travolt has been going through a
tough time I've heard about that so far
four men have come forward to accuse
Travolta of improper sexual advances
now one accuser said Travolta engaged in
lewd behavior during a massage session
back in January of course nobody knows
what really happened but we were able to
recreate the accusers testimony with the
help of the Conan peanut players John
Travolta allegedly met the massage
therapist online and arranged to pick
him up in a black SUV the star of such
films as Saturday Night Fever and pulp
fiction allegedly drove them both to the
Beverly Hills Hotel the first hour of
the massage went without incident
then Travolta allegedly became highly
around.but therapist he indicated he was
not interested but Travolta was
undeterred when the masseur threatened
to call the police
Travolta got upset and called him a
loser
loser Travolta drove him back to where
they had met yes sir please get out and
Hayden twice the agreed-upon price the
therapist is suing Travolta for assault
and emotional distress
[Music]
I think that's the worst Travolta
impression I've ever heard
absolutely